Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
No else.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by Linkedin and their job recruitment platform,
which offers a smarter system for the hiring process.
If you've ever hired anyone or attempted to do it,
you know that finding the right people can be extremely difficult.
And if you don't have a direct referral from someone you trust,
you're left to use job boards that don't really offer any real world networking
approach.
And when I mean by that is in contrast,
Linkedin,
which is the world's largest professional network,
has a built in ecosystem that allows you to not only search for employees,
but also interact with them and their connections and their former employers or
colleagues in a way that closely mimics real life communication.
More than 70% of the workforce in the u s uses Linkedin and more than 22 million
professionals view and apply to linkedin every single week.
Unlike generic job boards,
linkedin considers skills,
experience,
and location to match you with candidates,
making it easier to find quality candidates.
And,
uh,
maybe above all you can directly contact,
candidates,
connections to get a good sense of if they are a good fit for your business.
So visit linkedin.com forward slash Tim and receive a $50 credit towards your
first job post.
That's linkedin.com forward slash Tim Tim for $50 off.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton.
And I'd heard about Peloton over and over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike and the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose,
I've known him forever,
some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him,
I said,
dude,
you look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean after like 75 beers.
And he said,
I've been doing peloton five days a week.
Now that caught my attention because Kevin does nothing five days a week.
And you know,
I love you Kevin,
but it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually.
But peloton is an indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting classes into your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes taught by the world's instructors or find
your own favorite class on demand.
And in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions that are shorter,
like 20 minutes.
And I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone seems to have their favorite
instructor or you can select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that that along with the realtime leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller than you would expect so it can fit in
a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not and it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you might say ma accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever other supplemental bits.
And pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and those are in the accessory category,
so there's $100 off is a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else or are you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone.
Check out Peloton one peloton.com and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories including the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out,
one peloton.com code Tim.
Hello boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
My guest today is Nicholas Thompson on Twitter at [inaudible] Thompson.
He is the editor and chief of wired under his leadership.
Wired has launched a successful paywall,
a snapchat channel,
and an amp stories addition,
if I'm pronouncing that correctly,
I'm not sure if to amp or amp.
We'll get back to that is also been nominated for national magazine awards in
design and feature writing.
Thompson is a contributor for CBS News and regularly appears on CBS this
morning.
He is also a cofounder of the activist which I've had contact with going way
back in the day.
A National Magazine Award winning digital publication.
Prior to joining wired,
Thompson served as editor of New York or Dotcom for 2012 to 2017
before the New Yorker Thompson was a senior editor at wired where he assigned an
edited the feature story,
the great escape,
which was the basis for the Oscar winning film Argo.
In 2009 his book,
the Hawk and the dove,
Paul Nitsa,
George Kennan and history of the Cold War was published to critical acclaim in
February,
2018 Thompson cowrote wired's cover story inside the two years that shook
Facebook and the world and 11,000 were an investigation based on reporting with
more than 50 current and former Facebook employees.
Nick,
welcome to the show.
My pleasure and I appreciate you correcting or at least informing my
pronunciation of the the subtitle of your book.
Not An easy name to pronounce.
I was a favorite story about it.
As I was giving a talk about my book and was kind of like 10 minutes.
This guy runs out so knits up one of the characters in is my grandfather.
This guy runs out and at the end I asked the host,
I was like,
why did that guy leave?
It looks me.
He said he thought he was going to hear from niches,
grants.
I want to ask and I have many,
many in front of me that I will ask,
but I thought I would start with,
I chanced upon when doing homework
I'll lead into with just reading the line and it is,
he is also an instrumental guitarist who used to supplement his journalism by
playing on subway platforms.
Is that true that you used to play music to supplement your writing income?
Presumably?
I guess
the wrong word because I actually made more money.
Yeah.
When I was young journalist,
so let's say ages 21 to 24,
I played on finger Sabaton and the platforms in New York and you could make a
good amount of money.
You know,
I'd make $20 an hour.
Um,
you meet people,
it's really fun.
You learn a lot about the city.
It's good sort of forced practice for multiple hours.
You learn a lot about the trains.
I had a great time doing that.
Did you pick up any best practices for busking?
And then there are many people who play on the platforms.
I'm sure they make different rates.
So what are the,
what were some of the best practices or approaches it up?
We'll just kind of interesting is to figure out the style of music you play and
the demographics you kind of hit.
Um,
so if you're playing like super familiar stuff,
if you're doing kind of Beatles covers,
you can go in a hallway right where people will hear you for two seconds and
walk by.
Or you can be on a train platform in the trains come every two minutes.
Right?
Because people were just here yesterday and give you money if you're doing what
I was doing because like weird instrumental guitar music that people will only
like if they get a couple of minutes uninterrupted.
You've got to find a platform where you know there may not be a ton of foot
traffic but where the trains don't come very often.
So for me the place it turned out to be the best was the l train platform.
I'm on Sixth Avenue and 14th Street people,
no New York to be able to visualize it.
And what was good about that is that the l train comes relatively infrequently.
It's one platform with book trains going on either side of it.
It's not a split platforms.
You get people who are booked going both west and east and then it was kind of
like perfect for me demographically because it's where all the gay guys and
Chelsea got off and then we're all kind of the sort of [inaudible] young
hipsters are heading to Williamsburg.
So I got like a lot of demographics are going to like stop if they see a young
guy playing guitar and possibly give him money.
Yeah,
that was,
I really spent a lot of time thinking it through and that was the one I liked.
So what you do is you try to get there,
you know,
you don't want to be there at like three o'clock when schools get out.
Cause everybody's lights.
It's crazy.
People are yelling and nobody can hear you.
The kids are jumping,
the kids kind of make fun of you.
Um,
but you definitely want to be there during commute time and you definitely want
to be there at like nine o'clock at night.
And it's the rules,
at least back when I was doing it a lot are,
you know,
once you got a spot,
you keep that spot.
So it's until you either get bored or have to pee,
um,
that you have it.
So you,
you try to calm right at like three 30 and then hold it until 10 if you can.
Did you ever contemplate the Beatles route playing more popular music
or did you choose your,
your musical selection for other reasons besides the $20 an hour?
Yeah,
it would have been,
the thing is that I'm not good at,
I'd Beatles covers.
Right.
And like I have like a limited,
I have a very conversation is if I have a limited skill set.
Right.
I'm very good at writing my own like multitenant acoustic instrumental guitar
songs and I am really bad at reading music and played other stuff.
So I never had that choice.
But it would be an interesting choice.
Right.
Do you go for,
if you had the capacity to do both,
which do you choose?
Do you choose the one that gets you more money and is a little less emotionally
fulfilling?
Uh,
it's like a typical electric we have in a thousand moments in life.
Unfortunately,
I didn't have to do that in this particular,
so when music stage of my career.
Why did you choose writing full time
music full time?
MMM.
It seems like both paths are presumably difficult,
right?
I mean,
you are a creator in both paths.
Uh,
I don't know if that's a bad question,
but it just comes to mind.
It's like you seem very talented.
I think that what was interesting is that they were kind of competitive with me.
Right.
And so the that go into how much time do you prioritize playing music?
How much time do you prioritize data journalist includes factors like how much
do you make per hour,
but also as time goes by,
how do you expect your life and ambitions to grow?
And the thing about being a musician is that I kind of,
I could see the end point,
right?
I didn't think I was going to become a transcendent,
really good musician.
I didn't see a career where I would like change the way music was made or you
know,
create a new sound.
Like I didn't,
I didn't think that even if I devoted myself to a completely for 10 years,
I'd ever reached that high point.
So I could kind of see the Max that I would get through.
Whereas in journalism,
the Max was quite a bit higher.
So as the,
you know,
as the earnings began to equal out of it began to earn more as a journalist.
Um,
I started to gravitate more more towards that.
so it was,
it was a combination of having some success as a journalist and then also
thinking through like what would a life as a musician do you like versus what
would life as a journalist be like for somebody with my skeleton?
As I said earlier,
my skills as a musician or limited,
right.
I could,
I could do well at one thing,
but I didn't think I was going to really make a life for it.
That why do you recall any particular moment?
It could be at any point in your life,
this writing thing or this editing thing,
something related to long form text is something that I could really be
excellent at or this,
this is something that I think I could make a good living doing because
I can be exceptional at this.
Was there a moment where you had that thought that would compel you to pursue
that say instead of the music?
Yeah.
The funny thing is that in my mind to those foundational years,
let's say from when,
from the time I graduated college to the time I completely committed to it as
it's to be a journalist was 29.
It wasn't,
it wasn't always music versus journalism,
you know,
in those early years of his music versus journalism and other things.
And then it was journalism versus other things.
Um,
you know,
he had finished college.
I thought I was going to be sort of an environmental activist or am I going to
politics.
Um,
I got kind of put in,
tracked into journalism kind of a slightly odd way we can,
we can get into.
Um,
so it was really only at about 29 when I got hired by wired,
um,
and started to do a good job at it in stories.
And when I started writing,
writing my book about Nixon Cannon,
that I began to feel really comfortable,
confident about it as a career choice.
You said,
I think you just attract into journalism in an odd way.
Sorry,
I should have known you're going to come with that.
I can't pick that up.
Pick that up.
Right.
Let's jump.
Let's jump into it.
It's super bizarre.
So I,
when I was in college,
I was focused very much on being like a good college student and succeed in a
college and like going into student government and getting good grades,
but I was two degree.
That's strange.
When I look back,
it did not think at all about what would happen,
right.
I went to Stanford,
had a graduate school fellowship,
like I did,
I did well in college,
but I've prepared for life post college extraordinarily badly.
Um,
and so I graduate and then maybe the fall after I graduated where I'm playing
guitar,
um,
I get,
I meet somebody at a party and sort of get surprisingly hired as an associate
producer at 60 minutes,
which is a great job.
And so I moved to New York.
Um,
I show up at CBS or 60 minutes is,
and within an hour I'm fired
within an hour.
Who are you?
I was being hired at a position,
sort of beyond my stature.
It was very strange and in retrospect it's one of the things where I was,
I was treated kind of awfully,
but anyway,
understand it.
I was 22 so I go,
I show up,
I'm just don't remember it.
And this guy's name was still chef Larry's like,
who are you?
I'm,
I was like,
I'm the new associate producer.
I'm working under.
Steve Cross is like,
what have you done in television before?
I was like,
nothing,
you know?
And he's like,
well,
what if you'd done professionally before?
I was like,
nothing.
I just graduated and he's like,
and we hired you as an associate producer.
I was like,
yeah,
you know,
I did these interviews and that's found in these tests and he's like,
you're fired.
And like they literally took me out of the building
gets worse.
So
that's,
that's I think December of 1997 I graduated college in June of 1970 that's
December of [inaudible] 97 so I'm like,
Whoa,
what am I going to do now?
One of my best friends from college was starting graduate school in the fall and
he was about to leave for Africa.
And so I was like,
I'm coming with you.
So I go and I get my vaccinations and within two weeks I'm on a plane and then I
get kidnapped immediately upon landing.
Right.
Right
to attend years.
Um,
and I pull out my guitar to subway platform in Tangiers them alone at this point
and see in northern Morocco,
he was a guy comes up to me is like,
Hey,
you know my family plays music,
you want to come home with me?
I'm like,
great.
Yeah,
sure,
why not?
I've got a day here before I'm 60,
my friend and it turns out that he's like,
he's a drug dealer.
He locks me in this room and he these cockamamie plans where he wants me to
distribute as drugs around America and he makes me to fish head.
Very peculiar,
but it's definitely not what,
it's definitely not come home to my family and play guitar.
And so I've off to a pretty rocky start in Africa and eventually he dumped me
and says,
enough of this guy like you,
I'm not getting what I want to Id and just like dumps me and lets me make my way
to the train station.
Um,
but the funny thing about it
definitely not equipped to be a proper drug dealer for me in the United States.
I mean what was the kind of the straw that broke the camel's back where he's
just like enough of you,
I'm letting you go.
I mean,
did you have an approach?
How did you get out of that?
I was very confused.
I think what happened was,
I don't think he had like begun that day saying I'm going to kidnap and
American.
I think it was more like he saw me sitting there,
I was like,
let's see what happens.
I take this guy,
right?
And then I go there and he goes through my stuff and it goes through all my
stuff,
like looking for money and he finds that I've only got,
I think it was $60 in cash and there's no traveler's checks.
And fortunately I had a backpack that had like smuggling sections built into it.
And so my passport,
um,
and like the valuable stuff were in there.
And so I think he went through all my stuff and decided that I was like an
itinerant traveler who was useless.
I don't know what answers I gave him,
um,
about,
you know,
being a drug mule for him that turned them off.
But,
um,
it didn't,
it didn't work out.
It was,
it was a poor job.
Apathy,
okay,
come with what I wanted.
So,
so he dumped me and got rid of me.
And then the great thing is that I then had a story.
And so I turned that experience,
um,
and some other experiences I had in Africa.
I then spent several months traveling with my,
my friend and some other friends.
I turned those into an essay,
um,
for the Washington Post's.
So suddenly I had journalists eclipse and so kind of inadvertently hadn't been
fired from journalism.
Um,
I used to the experience with follow to get clips and then I came back,
I played guitar.
Um,
and then those clips led to a job as the editor of the Washington weapon,
which was a place that hired sort of young,
ambitious people into roles with low paying roles,
but high responsibility where you learn a lot.
So that was how I got going in journalism.
It was very bizarre.
The Washington Post or why did you end up,
was it a cold query or just a cold email to one of the editors he found on the
masthead?
Or how did you go about getting this published?
I think that,
I think it was a cold query.
Um,
I know that I had talked to some journalist before I left.
I remember talking to somebody from the Boston Globe.
I grew up in Boston about,
you know,
it's interesting things happen to me.
Would there be,
would it be possible to write stories,
um,
from locations in Africa?
And so I had gotten some advice,
um,
but I think,
I think
just get kidnapped
if I got something,
my friend said to me,
he like,
well,
you know,
to have that experience and only lose dollars,
it's kind of worth it.
I wouldn't say that.
I was like so shaken by the whole thing.
I was like,
oh you jerk.
But he was totally right.
Um,
it turned out to be like a really interesting experience for a mere $60.
I saw this woman in New York City at one point walking around with the tee shirt
is the crop top that said bad decisions make good stories and they didn't quite
know how to take the shirt like in the context of her walking around with it,
but certainly true for standup comedians and it would see him true for
people in northern Africa considering perhaps a path in journalism.
Let's jump forward and I'm sure this is going to be very non linear and how we
bounce around.
But one of the things that I mentioned in the intro was this piece,
the greatest scape that later was turned into Argo.
And when I was doing some writing on this,
a line that jumped out at me that I wanted to dig into was at wired,
at least at the time,
every pitch was graded on a scale of one to six by everyone on staff and a
there's a meeting where these story ideas or are pitched,
uh,
and uh,
or then presented rather in reverse order of their scores along with their
standard deviations,
which is fantastic.
But uh,
could you walk us through that pitch grading process and tell it,
tell us the story of the great escape.
Because my understanding is that it wasn't a,
it wasn't an immediate point to center field hit home run type of story.
But I,
I'm most curious in the grading process and how you guys do.
So that was the wired was run by this guy named Chris Anderson,
who had been the writer at the economist and just a really high Iq silicon
valley type and a very mathematical way of looking at the world.
And so this efficiency mechanism he brought into the pitch process was to run it
like sort of a false democracy under a dictatorship.
So the final decision would be made entirely by Chris,
whether a story with a sign or not.
But when you wrote a pitch,
he would be sent to everybody on staff and everybody would vote on it and grade
it.
And the theory was,
if you,
it was kind of a wisdom of crowds theory that if you've got everybody's vote,
you could immediately tell what was great and what was bad and that I think he
genuinely believed that.
One of the things that happens in meetings is that you spend a lot of time
discussing stuff that 95% of the room hates.
But since only a couple people talk,
you can't quite determine that quickly.
And so this is a way of determining what is the stuff that 95% of the room loves
and 95% of the room hates immediately,
which is a super interesting thing,
right?
It's like theoretically a great thing to do.
But problem with that is that it can be really demoralizing when your pitches do
badly,
but it's okay to get your picture Jackie by the editor in chief.
But to have your pitch,
you know,
graded badly by all your colleagues was kind of mostly rough.
So for the great escape,
I remember this really well.
So just writer Joshua Bear who's,
he's like great stuff for this American life is here,
all kinds of wonderful essays.
He was a little,
you know,
we're quite a bit younger then.
Um,
I remember he sent me a bunch of pitches.
I can't remember what the whole packet was,
maybe somebody,
three ideas,
but one was,
and at the spy he's got the story of a crazy escape from Iran.
And then another one I remember on the same email was,
uh,
I think stolen,
tried to create a half man,
half ape army.
Yeah.
And so like the two things were together,
like should we investigate Stalin's half man,
half of,
of army or should we investigate like this escape from Iran.
And so through whatever process of conversations between editor and writer dress
and I decided to pursue the escape from Iran and I pitched it at the meeting and
I knew it was going to do badly.
Right.
Cause it wasn't a wired story.
It's like from the 1970s,
um,
it's not about,
you know,
how Amazon and artificial intelligence chickens and I was just wasn't core
wired.
Um,
and it's,
everybody voted it really badly.
Right?
The scores are one to six.
It probably got a score of 10 is something on the other hand,
Bob Cohen,
who was the executive editor,
the number two person there,
I remember it,
the pitch meeting just being like,
it's not wired but I love it.
Let's do it.
And so he just sort of muscled it through.
So again,
it was democracy under a dictatorship and the dictators,
uh,
wanting to do the story,
um,
because it was such a cool,
so manifestly,
you know,
riveting narrative.
So we ended up assigning it.
Josh wrote it,
did a great job,
um,
published it,
and then Hollywood took an interest.
What makes it good?
Let's just assume for the time being,
it was a good set of,
this is going to sound funny to people who don't have the background,
but we could talk more about stolen anyway.
Leave that alone for now.
Well,
like there was a real missed opportunity.
Like we would have found out there wasn't a half man,
half a farm.
It could be an amazing,
not only that,
but you have a,
correct me if I'm wrong,
just from the Internet.
So who knows?
But a long friendship with Stalin's daughter,
is that right?
Yeah,
that is,
that is very true.
Happy to talk about that.
Yes.
That line and I were friends from many,
many
blip with putting aside the half man,
half ape army of stolen question mark.
What,
what makes a good pitch?
If a,
if a writer is pitching someone like you,
uh,
what,
what is a good pitch look like?
What are the,
what are the ingredients?
What are common mistakes that make something a bad pitch?
However you want to kind of answer that for folks.
Yeah.
Yep.
So a couple of elements that I appreciate our,
when the writer gives options,
right?
So what Josh done in that email is he had sent three ideas,
which I think is really great,
right?
And it's useful to be able to pick and it gives you a sense of the person's
reinjured mind.
Another element that's very useful is the element of pitch that answers the
question,
why am I the person to do this?
So in Josh has pitched,
the reason he was the person to do it is that he had found something that no one
had known before and to um,
had unique access to the key character,
right.
Had access to the spine.
Tony Mendez,
I think this was his neck.
Um,
so that's another important element.
And then the third is understanding what the magazine is trying to do in this
section you're trying to write for him.
So what wired was trying to do and it's feature well then as now was tell really
important stories about how technology is changing the world,
but also tell things that are cinematic and fun to read and that are part of the
wired world.
So this story,
you know,
the great escape wasn't going to change the way you think about tech,
but it had characters,
right?
It had emotional residence.
It had like there was a movie you could play in your mind is you have Ben
Affleck later show without question.
Um,
and that's often a question I'll ask you the story.
So how will there be to be able to visualize it?
How will they be emotionally attached to it?
Why will they care about the characters you introduced at the beginning of what
happens to them at the end?
So a good pitch is something where you're writing in a way that makes the editor
convinced that you'll be able to write well,
it shows why you have special knowledge or special insight or special access
that shows why the story is new and that,
you know,
is structured.
So that the fit club,
that pitch clearly fits the aims and goals of the magazine or publication you're
writing for
or is it just assumed a given lengths or a lead time for completion?
Is any of that included in that initial pictures that,
does that come,
does that come later or is it just,
yeah,
but public comes later.
Um,
if it's somebody who I've worked with specifically,
um,
they may say,
hey,
I'd like to do this,
um,
this month or I want to fit it into my calendar.
Or you know,
I'm planning to go to location TK in June and I could do at Penn.
But normally it's more like this is a story I'd like to do in the next
reasonable timeframe.
So just want to back up for a second.
For people who don't know what TK means,
as I understand it means to come,
but it's spelled t k so that you can find it very easily when you search for it.
That's my understanding at least.
And yes,
because very few words in the English language have t and K so you can do a
control f and find the things that you need to spot really quickly.
So for people who are wondering why TK,
uh,
you know,
a friend of mine,
Neil Strauss,
uh,
will turn off his Wifi when he writes and not interrupted for fact checking and
certain types of research and just drop TK and throughout the piece and then do
that as a batching process later just for people.
Yeah.
So for people who are wondering about that,
uh,
he also uses an APP called freedom to block the Internet so that he can be
disruptive.
So it's a good thing to do.
So now you just described Chris Anderson's process,
which fits his personality and I've met Chris before.
Very smart guy.
What is your process?
How does your story pitch process differ?
Pretty similar actually.
I mean,
we've gotten rid of the score isn't the standard deviations.
I thought that probably
a little bit too much stress and unnecessary anxiety for people.
Um,
but there is value to it.
I can see what we do is a similar process.
So the writer will work with an editor and they'll come up with a pitch.
We try to make sure that they're under the page just to respect everybody's
time.
And because constraints lead to better work in general.
Um,
so people send in a one page pitch,
we sit around in a room and lots of people are invited,
editor,
the editors will be signing.
The story's kind of sit around.
The main table story comes up and we talk about it.
We talk about what are the unanswered questions?
Well,
the writer,
he be able to do that.
What are the unanswered questions?
Sorry to interrupt.
Like a lot,
a lot of pitches will,
um,
there'll be missing that element of how,
of what the scenes will actually be and who,
how the characters will develop,
right?
It's like,
here's a big idea.
Here's an important thing that happened and I'm going to write 5,000 words about
it.
And there's almost no thing that is big or important enough that you can write
5,000 words about it if you don't have like specific scenes and visual moments
where you can pull a person in.
And again,
this is for wired features track and we run like web stories.
We have a much more informal process.
We weren't short things in front of book where there's a more informal process,
but you know,
we only run four features a month,
48 of them a year.
So we do discuss them all and whether,
you know,
there'll be able to pull it off and how will the chronology work.
And then there's a lot of discussions about the writers because an incredibly
talented magazine feature writer,
sort of a subset of ideas.
They could write about it as a lot larger than somebody with more limited skills
and experience in this particular cracked.
Um,
so we'll talk about,
okay,
well what have you read by this person?
Or I remember reading that story,
I didn't take it totally worked or I read that story.
It did work very quick,
quite well.
So that's how it works.
We all talk about it and then afterwards I'll speak with the executive editor,
a couple of other editors,
and we'll make a decision.
Red Light,
green light,
red light,
green light.
We're going to talk about,
I'm going to tie it in here because my understanding is that you've had a decent
amount of exposure to two feature pieces being optioned for film and Argo or
rather the great which then became Argos is one such example.
Uh,
a lot of,
a lot of writers dream of having things optioned.
It's by the coach.
My questions I suppose,
are a,
is it a dream worth having a or is it just almost uniformly disappointing,
uh,
or somewhere in between.
And then B,
if you,
if you were having something option of yours,
what are the deal points or this the,
the deal structures that you would pay attention to?
Oh,
that's interesting.
Um,
before
I started getting a reputation as a place where stories were optioned and has
had a good amount of success in the activist,
which we started in 2009 has had success from the get go.
I mean it's something like 25% of the stories that had run in the out of his
tablet option to Hollywood,
which is a crazy,
crazy percentage.
Maybe it's 30%.
Um,
and so is it a dream worth?
Having the effort is a dream of having,
um,
the most important thing is having a good agent who has actually sold films
before.
Not like a lot of writers,
don't know the right agents and having the right agent just as utterly
transformative.
It takes you from,
you know,
almost no chance to a very good chance.
Um,
so having an agent who has actually had success selling magazine stories at
Highland for is really important.
And so what we did at the atmos as we just started out with the agent who had
had a lot of access to the same guy that we had used at,
um,
that I,
that my cofounder had around a little bit of writer for wired and that I had
used at,
um,
at wired.
And so we just brought them in with the,
out of this,
from the,
from the Gecko or from fairly early on.
Um,
and then when you're looking at the deal points,
um,
you know,
what you want is,
there's a whole series of stages along the way where you get different paths,
right?
You get an initial amount of money and then you get certain renewals and then if
the script is written and then at the movie was made.
And so what you want are you want to make sure that high quality people are sort
of being added at each step so that it's more likely to move from a to B to c to
d.
Um,
and that you,
um,
you don't kind of fall for the,
the dream where it's like,
alright,
we'll give you $1,000 now,
but $1 million,
we make it.
Um,
and there's almost no chance we'll make it right.
You want to make sure that you get paid real money upfront because even a really
good script with really good people attached to it as a fairly low percentage of
chance of getting through.
Certainly it seems that way.
Yet there are some that make it through
the greatest scape,
for instance.
What are there any other clauses that are particularly important?
And I,
I've never,
I've had for the first book that I did,
I've had folks approach me about film adaptation.
Um,
but it,
it seemed like
sh
it least in the structures that are being offered,
it was very much a lockup period with almost no monetary compensation with no
guarantee that they would actually do anything with it.
In the sense that the reversion of rights clause became really important to
consider.
Much like if you're a product developer or an inventor and you develop something
that you want to license to a larger company,
there's nothing compelling them to spend marketing dollars on it or to develop
it or push it in less or I should say you increase the likelihood of that if you
have that dictated in the terms of the contract and then some reversion of
rights clause.
Right.
So,
I suppose what I'm wondering is how much time in your mind do you allow for a
story to float out there in the ether of say Hollywood before you can you pull
it back in some fashion or,
or allow it to take a different path?
Potentially.
Because I know friends who are writers who've had stuff just float around and
So-and-so's attached,
but oh no,
they're not attached because they're busy and then when this person's attached,
no,
they're not because they had a conflict and it just goes on and on and on for
years and years and years.
Is there any,
yeah.
Any,
any ways that you've found to mitigate against that in any way?
Yeah,
so I'm not,
you know,
this is not my area of topics for you spend a couple of things.
One,
I think that the value before you publish and before you put up for auction,
locking a few things down is really important.
Making sure you have the life rights to the central character that you
negotiated.
You know,
in the example in the Argo story,
it was really important that Josh had locked up rights to Tony men as a story so
that,
um,
after the story ran,
it wasn't like somebody else could do the same story but without Josh attached
to it because Josh and Tony came as a package.
Um,
and so they had negotiated a deal together.
And so that's a really important thing to make sure that you have as much as you
can,
the rights to that particular story buttoned up because it gives you just much
more leverage if potential bidders are like,
mm,
you know,
I can probably do this without nick.
Um,
or I can probably do this without buying the rights to make story because it's
public domain or so talking to an agent and working through that I think is
really important.
And then just knowing that,
you know,
there's no part of the world where people kind of tell more baloney stories
about how this is about the stars that are coming into Hollywood.
Like there's so many,
oh yes.
You know,
we'll attack Francis Ford Coppola,
right.
Well let's do this.
We'll do that and they're not lying.
It's just never true
to have it written down.
I think what people get caught,
right,
they sort of fall for that and what you need to do is you need to have an agent,
you need to have an auction,
you need to have a formal process,
you to get more than one person excited and you got two people bidding.
Then you have much more leverage on making sure that you get terms where you get
either a decent amount of money or a pretty good guarantee that will be made.
What we did at the atmos just we ultimately set up a first look deal.
I mean we work with a Hollywood studio that pays us an annual guarantee every
year to be able to read the stories before everybody else and to have the
opportunity to bid on them and so that was a way of getting guaranteed income,
making sure that somebody who was interested and kind of locking the process in
a way that worked for us.
That's great.
Yeah,
that's very smart.
I didn't,
didn't realize that.
For people who are wondering,
agent,
how do I get an agent?
How do I figure out who the agents are?
I'd love to hear it.
I'd love to hear your thoughts.
A very good starting place is to in my experience,
sign up for IMD,
be pro and look at the credits of different films that you've enjoyed,
uh,
or perhaps screenplays,
that,
uh,
that you might be interested in and try to trace back the roots of that way.
I am DB then provides say contact information for different actors,
directors and so on and you'll start to see certain names that pop up a lot like
William Morris Endeavor,
WME,
CAA,
creative artist,
agency,
UTA and so on.
Uh,
but uh,
would you have any other recommendations for people who want to educate
themselves about that side of the business per se?
I only have a recommendation would be to find friends or friends of friends who
have actually had success and say who sold it.
Right.
I didn't,
I do this much more in the book publishing world where a higher percentage of my
friends have sold books where you know,
you,
I know you sold the book,
what agent did you use and would you recommend him or her?
Um,
and then if you've got five people who full books,
you ask them all a couple of names to come up and you'd go and meet with them,
see who you click with,
who you get at a good bond.
We're having the best,
you know,
the best possible agent is somebody who has a track record and who actually
likes you and cares about you.
And sometimes those things are kind of like inversely related cause they have a
track record,
they have so many clients,
they're not going to care about you.
So you just kind of figure out how to find somebody who was both good and
responsive.
So on a segway to the New Yorker for probably more than a few minutes here,
I find the New Yorker fascinating as I do wired.
But uh,
in a,
uh,
it was 2015 interview you'd said.
And again,
fact,
fact correct as needed.
But the most encouraging thing we found is that the stories were prouder of the
stores.
We put more effort into attract more readers.
So the,
I'd love to talk about
what that means,
if you could elaborate on that.
Because as someone who
personally speaking for myself,
enjoys long form content and make some to resist the temptation to listicle
myself to death in hopes of eyeballs and clicks.
What,
what,
what did that mean and how did you foster that at the magazine
debates at the New Yorker on the print side when we really didn't,
when the magazine hadn't put a lot of effort into having an ambitious daily
website at the website of New York are mostly just published the print stories
and some of them are buying a paywall in,
some of them were not.
Um,
and then as part of this process where David became David Remnick to get much
more excited about daily journalism and the importance of having a website,
having Ventura was moved over to run the website,
um,
work with a bunch of people.
And so the initial challenge was,
you know,
can you publish daily content?
I think it's the magazine is put together by some many people with so much
experience.
And you know,
the website was this kind of startup within the organization where you have to
be a lot scrappier.
You're paying people,
you know,
a New Yorker writer will get several dollars a word to write 5,000 words.
So you're looking at $15,000 a story.
And on the website you're looking at $200 a story.
So can you produce content for that $200 that won't sort of detract from the
other stuff.
And that's a challenge,
right?
And you have to figure out what is the deal?
Maybe 800 words,
you know,
a thousand words.
I mean,
that was actually interesting conversation.
Like if you make 300 words,
you know,
will it actually detract more,
um,
that it can make it 800 words.
You should,
you make the web stories more like the long print stories or last light,
the long prince stories.
And so there's a lot of back and forth.
This is kind of the central debate in my mind for several years.
Right?
How do you make daily web content that feels of a piece with the New Yorker
magazine has and it's been around for 85 years and has such an incredible
history and such great stories.
Um,
and so back to the initial question,
over time,
we found that what got the most readership that work to the best in every sense,
we're smart pieces of analysis of what was happening right now,
ideally written by the same people who wrote for the magazine.
And they would spend far less time per word on their web post and they were for
the magazine stairs,
but they would feel related.
They feel other piece.
If you know,
Philip Duravit wrote a web piece about a terror attack that it just happened,
it would feel enough like a Philip very of its magazine feature and the readers
would appreciate it.
And so ultimately our strategy became getting the staff writers to write regular
posts,
hiring people who could write very quickly,
um,
could write it,
the cadence of the web,
um,
but who had similar pro styles to the New Yorker staff,
writers moving,
um,
John Cassidy for example,
who was a magazine that better right to call them every day for the website,
which is great.
Really able to have to know that every day you have a terrific column by the
Super Smart,
well respected guy.
Uh,
same with Amy Davidson who had been a senior editor,
so bringing over people,
bringing in new people,
getting some of the staff writers.
And what we found was that that the stuff people liked was the best stuff we
published.
And that was really heartening.
Like people didn't want to go to [inaudible] dot com to read,
to sort of click through.
Um,
yeah,
sensationalized light shows.
They wanted to come to New York or to read smart,
interesting things.
And that was great because when you're business incentives aligned with your
sort of journalistic incentives,
you're in a much happier place.
And if the two are sort of run perpendicular to each other,
I would love to get your health encouraging people to do more long form.
And by people,
I mean publishers to foster that type is going a patient editorial and in some
cases.
And so I'm going to make this really personal.
I've thought a lot about
hiring writers to do longer form pieces for my blog for instance,
which does not have the draw or cachet of the New Yorker certainly or wired,
but nonetheless decent amount of traffic.
You know,
I had a couple of million people,
a couple,
couple of million uniques per month.
And uh,
I think what struck me when I was trying to think through this as someone who
loves long form is that I didn't know the process.
It's harder,
it's more of a black box than trying to put together a list of 12 bullets or a
slide show,
which I'm not going to say it's mindless,
but it really doesn't require a lot of planning.
So if for instance,
I wanted to,
uh,
I had ideas for certain pieces and wanted to invite people who had ideas for
pieces,
who were qualified writers to do,
let's just call it three to 10,000 word pieces,
right?
It's a very broad spectrum.
What,
what is the process then for figuring out how much I should pay someone a in a
context like that?
Because you,
you noted yourself,
there's kind of a very wide,
uh,
there's very wide
spectrum of a thing that just used that twice in like three sentences.
So shame on me.
But nonetheless,
uh,
in terms of payment per word,
I don't even know how that works because I've never done it.
But how would you think about going about doing something like this?
If I wanted to do an experiment of like three to five pieces with different
writers and see how it goes,
uh,
how would you suggest I even think about this?
You have so much experience and I have none because everything on the blog with
a few rare exceptions have been my own stuff.
Yeah,
that's a really interesting question.
It's kind of like what we went through it,
the animus.
So first you could say,
all right,
well how much advertising revenue will I get?
Um,
and so you can do the math,
right?
So let's say you have,
you would get
50,000 people might read this story,
that's a lot.
But you know,
you,
you know,
through your social promotion and to general traffic to the site,
so 50,000 people or read the story,
um,
you will be able to sell your ads.
Like whatever CPM you sell,
let's say $15 per thousand visitors.
Um,
and you know,
you'll be able to show four ads per person,
you know,
one quarter of the people will be turning on ad blockers.
So we'll say three,
um,
and,
how much revenue you generate in total,
right?
And so you can go through those calculations,
You figure out what is your sell through rate on the advertising plays.
You see,
do you have of the right?
And the problem is when you do that,
right,
if you add those numbers up,
you're going to end up with,
you know,
generating for your story.
That has a couple of ads ads do you per person,
because that's people,
you're gonna end up generating like $2,000 in total revenue for the story.
Right?
It just,
the numbers are just not good.
Um,
and so if you have an advertising supported longform journalism shop,
it's really hard to pay for the writer and the editor,
the rights to the art.
Um,
and sort of the bandwidth.
It's a really hard thing to justify.
And that's something we thought through a lot at the New Yorker and a wire.
And if the activist,
okay,
so how do you make the economics work if you're only going to generate,
you know,
sometimes it's a couple hundred dollars in advertising revenue,
like what,
what can you do?
Well,
the New Yorker and wire,
there's a second revenue stream,
which is subscriptions,
right?
And so you generate way more money from subscriptions on these long form stories
than you do from Africa.
So suddenly the amount of total amount of revenue generated by a long story is
much higher,
right?
So suddenly you're generating,
you know,
$4,000 for a story or $5,000 for a story or whatever it is,
and you can justify paying higher rates.
The third way of making money is like find another thing.
So the activist,
it was Hollywood,
right,
where we could end up,
we would pay writers,
I think we would pay them.
Um,
well we had two different models,
but you end up being able to pay them much better rates because you know,
if they agreed that they will give you 50% of the option price if they sell it
to Hollywood.
So we would bake that into our contracts.
Like you know,
either we can pay you $2,000 to this story and you can keep all the rights,
the Hollywood rides,
or we can pay you $10,000 and give us 50% of the Hollywood money and then the
writer and generally,
which choose the second option to get the higher guaranteed payments so they can
justify spending all the time on it.
So with you,
you might want to think through something like that or think through whether
there's another revenue stream you can attach to or whether it's being part of
events or something like that or find a specific sponsor for a kind of story.
But that's how I would think through the economics of how to,
how to support it.
But again,
the core problem and the reason why it's really hard for publications to do long
form is that you know,
it takes a writer two months to write a story that will get 50,000 readers and
if you have that right or putting out listicles,
they'll be able to generate three of them a day,
each of which will get 25,000 readers.
And it's sort of the bang for the buck equation unless you change the economics
somehow by having six depends on new deals or something else.
All the economic incentives push people towards short stuff.
Odd position maybe in the sense that I don't,
I don't have advertising,
I don't have memberships.
I there's a possibility I could do something with Hollywood optioning.
There are just stories that I would love to have told and characters I know who
are just endlessly to me at least fascinating who I don't have.
I don't have current bandwidth,
maybe even the capability to do justice in a really long form piece and I would
love to just,
I want to just see it in the world and pay them to do that.
Probably reserve any option,
right.
For film or anything like that.
In the case that I'm paying them,
how would you,
how might you determine how to pay them in a scenario like that?
Is there,
if you're prepared to lose them,
if you're prepared to lose money on it,
then
prepared to lose money but not like hemorrhage out the face,
if that makes sense.
Right.
Like I'm,
I want to pay a fair,
you won't hemorrhage pay people $2 a word you get like all the best writers in
America would be thrilled to right for you.
You pay them a buck 50 word,
there'll be,
you know,
you'll get a slightly smaller pool you pay and people will be like,
yeah.
So your range will be somewhere between a dollar and $2 a word.
Cool.
You know,
if you're Michael Lewis,
you'll ask for substantially more,
but for like really terrific writers,
they will be happy with those rates.
Cool.
Amazing.
Well,
all right,
well I'm going to publicly say just for any writers who are listening,
I will pay you $2 a word given the ideas that I have.
So,
uh,
yeah,
just,
I mean,
that may change,
but for the first few pieces I want to do some,
some really,
there's some things that I've been thinking about and they've been eating up
like the ram in my,
the back of my mind for probably a year or two.
And I think there are people who are better qualified to tell some of these
stories.
So.
Cool.
Yeah.
Productive podcast.
Cool.
So I'll make this,
well,
I guess it is called the Tim Ferriss show,
so I shouldn't feel badly about being so self indulgent.
But let me move on.
Uh,
he,
uh,
also at the,
at the New Yorker,
uh,
the,
and this was in politico,
this is an interview.
So this is,
I suppose when you were a senior editor and it said you'd been responsible for
shaping the 10,000 word raw copy filed by writers.
Like,
and it went on with this amazing list of writers.
How,
how did you do what you did as an editor?
How does one edit these incredible writers who have 10,000 word pieces?
Like when you read a,
the first for I suppose first of all,
do you get a effectively finished piece?
Do they send you a first draft that is rough?
How do these writers work with you?
Or did they work with you that
the great thing about the New York that you may be a unique publication in
America and that kind of 90% of the content is written by 50 people.
And so you show up and they're whatever.
There are six senior editors.
That means that eight people work with you and see your life is about those
eight people.
So that making sure that they have the right ideas,
they're all working on the time that you're helping them maximize their talents,
their ambitions,
and helping them find stories.
And so I worked with a group of writers,
um,
and with all of them,
there were some things that I would do the same and some things that I would do
differently.
So first,
whenever they filed the draft,
I would immediately write back and say that I've got it.
Because even if they're the most talented writer in the world,
everybody is slightly insecure and wants to know that their story has been
received by the editor.
So I've got it.
Second thing is I wouldn't read it right then,
but I wouldn't,
um,
delay,
right?
Cause you just,
procrastination is the enemy of good editing.
You should just start and do it right.
And so if you get the draft while you're in the middle of something else
important,
like edited another draft,
of course you wait for an hour.
But really you should,
you know,
within the first six hours of getting a draft from the writer,
you should have read the draft.
And so then you read the draft and then you start thinking through,
and usually the first step would be going through and sending them back a memo
saying,
hey,
this is good.
You know,
these are the things I like,
but here are the big structural issues.
And actually giving them specific guidance.
And my goal was always to make it a memo that I wouldn't have to kind of,
uh,
men like you want to write and say,
I haven't really figured this out,
but I kinda think he might want to do this.
I'll tell you more tomorrow.
No,
you want to,
you want to give them,
give them actual advice and things they can work with.
And if they disagree,
they even have a conversation.
But I would write a memo saying,
hey,
this piece is strong.
You know,
I really like this,
but I,
you know,
I don't think you hit this core issue.
I think that the chronology is broken in these four ways.
I think you overuse this.
And I really think you need more important on that.
And so for every writer,
that's kind of the first step,
which is here's what I think is wrong with a piece.
And you,
you know,
you adjust that based on the amount of time you have allotted.
If it's like a political piece and it has to run next week,
you,
you know,
you try not to,
if they're only going to be able to jump over somebody that's four feet high
because the time available,
you try not to set up a barrier that's 65.
Right?
So that's the first step.
Then after that,
it starts to really vary depending on the writers.
So you know,
as you know,
each edit,
you know,
you go through a process from sort of wide aperture,
big comments to very narrow focusing on specific sentences at the very end.
Um,
and the process by which you go through that is different for different writers.
So I worked with Telefonica,
right?
One of the greatest pro status I've ever worked with,
and I would never adjust a sentence of his with my own process.
I would never say,
why didn't you write it this way?
How would you say,
I don't think this works.
Please rewrite it.
Or um,
you know,
please do this.
Not redoing it.
I would never,
I know never redo it myself,
but it works with a lot of other writers who I would be much more likely to say,
hey,
maybe you should write it this way or maybe you should do this.
Or even some writers where I would go in and rewrite sections with some writers.
Um,
I remember I worked with Ryan Lizza.
and you know,
he would always been in this crazy deadline,
right?
You'd have to write the leading from behind story and it has to run on Thursday.
Uh,
and so we would literally be in Google docs where I would be rewriting the
beginning of the piece while he would be writing the kind of things that we've
spent a whole weekend with him,
sort of,
you know,
filing down the story and me chasing him as an editor and then him sort of like
cycling back up and going through my addicts.
And that's just sort of looping through the piece with me trailing behind them.
So there were different,
different processes with different people.
But um,
that's kind of a guideline to how it works.
I know in a much more specifics on that because it's one of the things I
absolutely loved.
Do you become a good writer first and then a good editor or,
or can you do it the other way around for people who want to develop an eye for
editing,
uh,
suppose which is also very,
very closely related to rewriting.
Uh,
do you have any recommendations?
Are there any,
any books or classes or writers you would pay attention to perhaps to people who
are listening to say,
you know what,
I really want to develop a keener eye as a writer.
Slash.
Editor.
Yeah.
So a couple of things that I think are useful are,
well for first like get a better sense of style and structure.
So what are the things that I think was really important to me is that I found
the writers I really loved and I just read their stuff out loud for like,
that's the sort of forces a level of concentration and attention are pros.
I remember of go through the pieces of the freighter,
Katherine Boo Hoo.
Mediocre I thought was maybe the best status around it.
I would just read her pieces out loud.
Katherine Boo.
How do you spell um,
the Oh,
oh,
there we go.
And she wrote a lot of pieces about poverty.
Um,
her last book was about India.
She doesn't write a ton,
but what she writes was extraordinary.
You can also do it with,
you know,
Kalfas Center.
You can go back and do it and you know,
with John Mcphee or you could go and do it with rate from the whoever your
favorite,
your favorite writer or,
or,
or stylist is,
or even just a piece that you loved.
Um,
you know,
we've had all kinds of features and wire that are super interesting to read if
you read them out loud.
So find a writer you love for whatever publication and steadied them.
Right.
And think about what exactly are they doing.
I also,
um,
you know,
most of my training didn't,
this was done as an editor,
but you can also do it as a reader,
which is to map a story.
Um,
so I will often on a whiteboard when I'm working with a writer,
but you could also just do it as an exercise for the finished piece.
Like look at the structure at the piece,
right?
So how exactly does it work?
Where is information presented,
where characters presented?
So I'll use this example because it's sitting right here in my desk,
my 11,000 word story about Mark Zuckerberg that you mentioned at the intro.
It has a very specific structure that may not be the right structure or may not
be the ideal structure,
but it is a very deliberate structure.
So the way the story works is several characters are introduced.
And the story,
the First Section of the story is chronological from roughly February of 2016
two,
I think it's April of 2016 and tells the story of Facebook during that two month
period.
And then the piece that has its one jump back,
it goes and it tells me very quickly,
sorry if Facebook from 2007 to 2016 and an introduces several specific themes at
a couple of characters will become important later.
And that was very deliberately done.
Then the story drums backs into the chronology kicks up right where it was in
April of 2016 introduces a couple of facts that will be important later to the
story.
And then it mostly runs chronologically.
So it's the structure is 80% chronological and 20% sematic.
Um,
you know,
at certain points you have to introduce story's slightly out of chronological
court order because of where you are thematically in the story of what you're
talking about.
Russia,
you have to introduce the fact about Russia,
even if it doesn't exactly fit the timeline.
But my coauthor Fred Vogelstein and I worked really hard because as much as
possible make it chronological is very deliberate structural choices.
So you could map out that story and you know,
by mapping it out,
learn the things that I just said and also have a closer sense of the moments
where we chose to break away from the chronology.
Um,
and then be able to think through why we did that.
And so you can do that with,
you know,
most stories and you'll see flaws and some of them you'll see brilliance and
some of them you'll see,
you know,
chronological structure is not a particularly interested in structure,
but it's a very good one.
Um,
you'll see interesting ways to do it.
You can do it watching movies too,
but I think it's a really useful exercise will make you a better writer and
observer to there.
Take these things apart.
When you map the story,
which is a Whiteboard,
what does it look like?
Kind of bullet,
bullet,
bullet from top to bottom.
Is it set of circles going from left to right with things inside the circles,
outside the circles?
How do you map out a story if you're doing it on a whiteboard?
It's probably,
um,
it probably has,
I mean there are different ways to on the story,
but it probably has two things.
It probably has like
section,
right?
So section a,
you know,
the crime section be the chase,
right?
And then so sort of titles for all the sections and then sort of lines with the
different characters who are being introduced and where they're being introduced
and maybe even the different themes that are being introduced and where they're,
where they're being introduced.
So it's not really circles,
it's more like it's more,
it's close to the bullet points
recommendation I'd love to make for people.
Also,
this is,
this is something I really need to revisit my cell phone.
I'm not doing as much writing at the moment,
but for people who are really interested in structure and this mapping of
stories,
draft number four by John Mcphee is just a fantastic read and he really gets
into the weeds.
So you have to be exceptionally interested in writing to get into it.
But it shows some of the diagrams of his structure is for various feature pieces
that,
that he's written,
including for the New Yorker,
which is just,
I find it incredibly,
incredibly,
a fascinating,
uh,
given that if,
if anyone has not read levels of the game by John Mcphee,
I would,
cannot recommend it highly enough.
Um,
also from a structural standpoint,
that sort of chronology plus theme combination,
uh,
just,
just a Finn,
just a wonderful,
wonderful read.
Uh,
I'm going to tell a story about,
in some ways the reason why I ended up working at the New Yorker.
Um,
so I,
when I was at wired as a senior editor and the New Yorker reached out and said,
hey,
we've,
you know,
we've heard you're a good senior editor,
we have an opening in,
would you like to apply this?
And of course,
I mean,
I loved wire it in New York would be an amazing challenge.
And so I applied and I went through the process and the process was,
you edit to 10,000 word stories,
you rewrite things,
you,
it's exhausted process.
You've interviewed with the people.
Um,
and I went through it and I didn't get it.
And,
um,
but I could kind of sense in the note that they sent that I had been.
Um,
and then maybe,
so that was probably,
I think this is 2009.
It's probably October of 2009.
And then there was a holiday party in,
um,
December of 2009 where I met somebody who had been an assistant at the New
Yorker and they were like,
Nick Thompson.
Oh my God.
I went back and forth,
back and forth.
They almost it,
but I didn't hire you.
Right.
I said,
well,
that's interesting information,
painful.
But it's,
it's interesting.
I sit in two months later about February,
I had gotten,
um,
I knew I was about to receive weirdly,
sort of two other offers wanting to go into television and went to work for
another magazine,
both of which were very tempting.
And so I knew that I'd be switching my career as soon.
And I remember staying up late one night.
I read the,
um,
the shape of the bark canoe.
Bye.
Job Kind
of unknown book,
but just brilliant.
Yeah.
Beadwork
work is so good.
And so I read it and I finished it.
I remember lying on my couch,
it's like two 30 in the morning and I finished that.
I was so emotional.
I really,
I want to give the New Yorker another shop before I,
before I totally stepped away.
And so that night at two 30,
I sent an email to the deputy editor,
Pat Mccarthy.
Uh,
it's like Pam,
Dear Ms. McCarthy.
Um,
I know you almost hired me,
you know,
four months ago and I'm about to leave the company.
Wired is part of wired where I worked on where I work now as part of Conde Nast.
It to the yolk is also part of the second I'm about to leave the company to go
somewhere else,
but I really want to work for you.
So this would be the moment and I'd love to have another shot at it.
And it was kind of a strange email to send.
I was just sorta so emotional after reading the feet.
And Tim wrote back and was like,
okay,
let's come meet with me again and meet with rhythmic again.
And so,
uh,
I went upstairs to their office,
met with them again.
I'm Remnick was very blunt about why he hadn't hired me the first time.
Um,
asked me whether I could address the concern he had.
The concern he had was basically that you would come in on and um,
you want to write and do television and do all these other stuff instead of like
just putting your head down and beat an editor.
Um,
I said,
no,
I'll put my head down and be an editor.
I can prove it to you if you'll give me another edit test are they gave me
another at cast.
And then,
you know,
probably a week or two later they hired me.
So it was entirely a mic feet that,
um,
that spurred me to write that email to Pam and then got me hired.
Amazing.
What a great story
for people who really want to go down that rabbit hole brigade to cuisine.
There's so many,
oh my God,
it's,
you really can't go wrong with,
with big fee.
Yeah,
no,
that's a wonderful story.
How did you decide to get into the startup game startup game as a full contact
sport?
Generally?
Very,
very difficult.
How did that come into the fold?
So that happened.
Um,
so I was an editor at wired and at wire you pick ended that time under Chris
Anderson.
He really encouraged people to do different things.
I had done this crazy wonderful story where there's a writer,
editor atlas,
so I edited at wired,
awesome guy.
Um,
we had gotten very drunk one night and we were talking about for some reason
there were like a lot of people who were kind of faking your death and starting
life over.
Right?
Which is the interesting thing to do in the digital age because it's kind of
easier to start a new life and create a new identity,
right?
Just create a new email address and you tutor competence also easier to track
people.
So it was kind of an interesting wire dilemma and we were talking about how to
tell that story or two of her friends kind of segment gray and this woman,
Gen con four of us were having if e k and alcohol.
And somehow through this like long conversation,
Evan came up with this idea,
which is that he would write a story about how to fake your death and start life
over.
And then we would run it and then he would fake his death and we would run like
a man hunt the flag and we're not taking stuff.
But basically we go off the grid and wired would run them then how to find them.
This was early Twitter.
And so we took that idea to the wired kitchen meeting.
It kind of very high score got approved.
He wrote part one,
which is,
you know,
hear some stories about people who've tried to start over in the digital age.
And then he went on the run.
And so we ran this experiment for a month.
It was August of um,
I guess August,
2009.
And the experiment was Evan Ratliff has disappeared.
If you find him,
you get $5,000,
and then the rules were that I would have all the information or private
investigator would have.
So I would be able to interview with family members,
I would have access to his old photos,
like a social security number,
all those things.
And I would leak than out through Twitter over the course of the month.
And we had no idea it was going to work.
Um,
you know,
it's one of those things that like I've maybe he'll get found on the first day,
right.
Or maybe no one will care.
Um,
but
through,
uh,
I don't think I sleep,
I might've,
I at least
I certainly
friend's name his acts,
his
mother's name,
stuff you would have.
Um,
you know,
his credit card bills,
crazy people got so excited and it all happened on Twitter.
It's like the first time I was really into Twitter.
Um,
and so the deal is if the guy,
if he made it a month,
he got $5,000.
If you got caught,
the person got $5,000.
And so he got caught because he was using poor can skies is IP addresses masking
thing that nick is possible for people to see what Ip address he use.
But he's screwed up once and by screwing up once some smart code or figured out
a little bit about where he was,
then that guy figured out the fake Twitter account that haven't they created and
followed it by creating a fake
Fem Bot
following editor Evan.
They somehow then figured out that edit was in New Orleans.
We made a deal with will Shortz that if you solve the New York Times crossword
puzzle in bedded and it would be a clue about where Evan was.
That's,
I think the clue was something like,
um,
it'll be at a pizza restaurant and I had leaked online and he was gluten free.
So these geniuses online,
they're like solve the crossword puzzle and basically put together that there's
only one pizza place he can go to a New Orleans were search gluten free pizza
and they caught him on the last day.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Amazing Hunt.
Yeah.
So that was really exciting.
And so that happens.
And Evan and I of course bond despite the fact that I've almost heard his life
as the private investigator.
Um,
and so maybe a month after that,
Evan and I were,
the two months after that,
we were watching at his apartment watching a football game,
like an Alabama College football game.
Um,
he's from the south and it's written for them.
And he's like,
you know,
we should start a magazine that does that kind of thing.
And I was like,
sure,
that sounds like fun.
And I had a,
I just published my book and I had a really good web designer,
this guy named Jeff.
And I was like,
well,
let's meet Jeff and see whether he wants to do it with us.
And so the three of us got together and we said,
okay,
let's start a digital only magazine.
And so the idea was that I would keep my job,
the two of them would go full time to the outcomist.
Um,
we would,
you know,
run experimental story's crazy,
long form stories and see what we could do.
And then right about that time apple introduced the IPAD.
So then the idea became they'll,
you'll kind of be iPad focused and we'll do multimedia.
And so we started this company at ad super propitious moment.
Um,
in order to create the stories,
Jeff had to write a content management system that would make it easiest for us
to do multimedia storytelling.
And so accidentally we suddenly had a business too because then we were able to
license the content management system,
the people.
So we built a really cool business.
Um,
so the goal hadn't been to start like a software company and fulfilled another
software company.
The goal had been just like,
let's make a cool magazine that does longform.
Um,
and we inadvertently built a good business.
and so,
you know,
nine years later we still got it.
It's still publishing every month and there's still will CMS that we're still
selling.
What was the name?
Did you recall the headline?
The title of the piece about,
uh,
well I suppose it wasn't about Evan at this point,
but about people starting over in a digital world.
Do you recall or how or
how might people find
if they type in wired fanish
you'll find it or if you had an on that list rhe l I S S I think that headline,
it's like in Spanish.
And then Ratliff tried to disappear.
Here's what happened.
And it will tell because after he was,
after he got caught,
he wrote this great 8,000 word story about his life on the run.
So good.
Um,
it was the first door from what I'd ever nominated for National Magazine Award
and feature writing.
Um,
it's such a good story.
So yeah,
Evan Ratliff tried to vanish.
Here's what happened.
Looking for his name and vanish also lead to the proceeding piece that he had
written about.
Yes,
definitely.
Okay,
very cool.
Yeah,
that's an ongoing fantasy,
although increasingly difficult to get some good advice,
but maybe a little bit out of date,
additional tracking.
So you be my by any objective measure,
have gotten a lot done and get a lot done.
Uh,
love to talk about structure and routine,
not in writing but in your life.
And uh,
this,
this was as good a place as any to ask.
Do you still run to and from work or how,
how long you do?
So,
all right.
So what I have here is you run to work,
shower at the gym next door,
and then you have suits in the office to change into.
And then at the end of the day you change back into running clothes and run back
home.
Uh,
why is that important to you?
Have you always been running?
Yup.
Yeah,
so I was a runner in high school and college.
I took some time off,
but I started sort of marathon and recently,
seriously,
mentally twenties.
And it's important for all types of reasons.
It's important.
It has a sense of self,
it's important.
Um,
physically it's important to have physical things.
When does this one gets older?
And the my early forties.
Now it's important,
you know,
mostly because at one point in my life I got very sick and so it's a reminder
when I can still do it that I'm no longer that.
So there are a lot of like intense reasons why,
why I run into,
I like to run.
But it's really hard to find time to run.
I cause I have this ambitious job.
I work super late every night and I've got three kids and I'm a very devoted
father,
so I need to do with that in the morning.
I need to be a felony evenings.
Um,
so I can't kind of take off and run.
and in fact it's often harder to find time to run on weekends and doesn't the
weekdays.
So having it structured into my life where,
you know,
I put myself a wallet and keys and a little like a little pack strapping on,
on your own home.
It a,
it works really nicely and it keeps me,
I think it's also a good mental break.
You know,
you spend the morning with the kids,
getting them ready.
You know,
there's a lot of energy and excitement.
Um,
and then,
um,
when I go back home,
you know,
there's a lot of energy,
excitement and putting them to sleep and then kind of going back to work.
Um,
so it's nice to have like the little breaks in the day where I'm wearing
running.
If you're open to talking about it.
You mentioned you had a period where you've got very sick,
which I don't know anything about.
Could you tell us a bit more?
There's nothing
about on the Internet.
I got thyroid cancer,
which is,
it's cancer,
which is a horrible,
terrible thing,
but it's the,
it's kind of the least dangerous kind.
Um,
but what had happened with running is,
um,
I'll,
I'll sort of tell that whole story.
Um,
when I started running and started running marathons and like I remember really
wanting to break three hours.
I went as a child,
I'd watched my father,
he'd run a marathon,
was like three hours and 10 seconds.
And he had been frustrated that he couldn't run a three hour marathon.
And so I started running marathons and I like couldn't crack it.
And then one year and like totally cracked it and ran a two 43 right.
And it was like way underneath it.
And my dad was super proud.
And then right after that,
um,
I got diagnosed with thyroid cancer and I ended up having a couple of surgeries
going through radiation treatment.
How did you diagnose?
It was during a routine
checkup.
Yeah.
I was like,
it was like a couple of weeks after the marathon.
It was marathons in November.
And so it was early December and doctors like there's a lump,
it's probably nothing,
but let's check it.
And so he checked it and it was like,
oh,
we might be bad,
you know?
And then you go through that whole process that people who have been sick go
through where you know,
oh no,
this could be bad,
but it'll probably be okay.
Brian,
I'm in my twenties I've always been healthy.
Oh No.
It looks like it might be bad.
Oh No,
it is bad,
but it won't be that bad.
Oh No,
it is that bad.
Right.
And you'd sort of go through three months of these tests and experiments and
biopsies as you either like you either exit or you like it,
just get ever deeper into it.
Um,
you know,
at one point I remember if they start actually,
oh no,
you're okay.
Um,
but any case,
so I went,
then I went through the surgery to have it all removed and then the radiation
treatment and then a sort of titration of the medicine to try and get you back
to normal.
And it just completely obliterated me.
Uh,
it was the first time in my life that I'd been just,
just knocked off my feet and I couldn't,
like,
I couldn't run,
you know,
like 15 feet.
Right.
Um,
so that was a really tough emotional period for all kinds of reasons.
You know,
you're thinking about mortality in a real way.
For the first time it was my early twenties,
um,
I had just been married,
you know,
thinking about what,
what now would I ever be able to have children?
Like what,
what your,
your expectations on what life becomes totally different.
Um,
and so I went through that period and fortunately came out the other side and
then it was really emotionally uplifting and psychologically powerful when,
I guess it was two years after that first marathon,
I think in that first marathon,
I finished it in like two hours,
43 minutes and 52 seconds.
And then like two years later I ran the same marathon and finished it in like
two hours,
42 minutes and 50 seconds or something like that.
Um,
and it was incredibly powerful to suddenly feel like in a way that signal that I
was through it.
And so every year since then,
I've more or less every year since then,
except the years I've had kids,
I tried to run the same marathon.
That's ties you back to the original story.
I don't run it.
Thank you for sharing that.
Your bio or read about all the things you've accomplished and assume that it's
just been the one kind of home run after another after another,
aside from that kidnapping in northern Africa,
which turned out to be a blessing in disguise of sorts.
But,
uh,
I appreciate you sharing that.
And to further sort of flesh out the picture just a little bit,
could you tell us about a time when you felt,
aside from that particular period when you felt overwhelmed or,
or our director prepared any,
any of that and how you found your way out or what you do in those
circumstances?
Well,
there been,
um,
you know,
my,
my professional career in my,
you know,
the first six or seven years was who's not great.
Um,
I,
you know,
so I,
I finished school,
I have that kind of messed up period where I,
you know,
go to Africa.
I read through the post,
but it's,
you know,
it's a period of getting rejected by 20 jobs before I get hired the last
monthly.
So then there's like a moment of often this where for two years I'm editor to
watch a Monday going back to New York plenty of time the weekends,
but to wash them off the job is very much a two year job.
And the expectation when I finished was like all previous editors and watched a
month thing.
I would go on and have an awesome career in journalism.
I finished,
you know,
I think I finished like September 9th,
2011.
Um,
and after I finished,
I had a really rough time.
Um,
I couldn't get hired.
I,
you know,
I got rejected by 20 journalistic institutions.
I was sure I was going to hire the New York Times.
I didn't get hired to their time to first contact the Washington Post.
And you know,
I thought I had,
um,
it just,
it didn't work.
I ended up,
I ended up installing the new America Foundation,
which was fine.
Um,
but from roughly 2001 the 2005,
I couldn't,
I couldn't get journalism going again.
Um,
and so in the summer of 2005,
I guess in 2005 I was working at a magazine called legal affairs,
which I will like.
It was really grateful to,
but it wasn't,
he was in new haven.
My girlfriend,
who's now my wife was in New York.
Um,
I,
you know,
I applied to law school,
which is the way you get out of journalism,
right?
In the way you retract your life,
If you're in your 20s and the career you're doing is not working,
one great way to be track your life is through law school.
Uh,
so I applied to law school and I got into Nyu and I was literally set to go,
um,
I guess it would have matriculated in August of 2005.
Um,
I think wired rope to me in July of 2005 cent here.
Were you interested in being a senior editor?
And so that summer,
um,
it was crazy,
right?
Cause my whole life is going to,
I know it's going to hinge on this decision,
right?
Am I going to stay in journalism and or am I going to go to law school and then
like do something completely different.
And the way it all shook out,
I remember the,
the,
I hadn't,
I don't think I had been offered the wire job,
but I was pretty sure I was going to get it.
And so the day before I was due at Nyu,
I wrote to them and said,
no,
I'm not going.
And then I just prayed a lot.
They
get it and I started at next month.
Um,
but it was,
that was like,
those were a couple of years where I was like enough time to make the right
decision.
Like,
cause I remember when I had been like a teenager,
I hadn't expected to be a journalist so I had all this self doubt about whether
I had ended up in the wrong profession accidentally.
Where could,
if you look at your life as you know their purse when you're 25 and you think
back to what would nick had thought at 19 the the funny turn into journalism,
which now seems so propitious and so good at the sort of the weird story where
I'm kidnapped and I write the story and a good hire at the,
washed him up in and attracts me.
Like if you look at it from now,
it looks like a really fortunate thing that those things happened.
But if you're in your mid twenties in journalism,
is it working?
And you look at it and think,
wait,
I wasn't supposed to be a journalist.
I didn't want to be a journalist.
So maybe that just all got me going on the wrong foot and I should have,
like if I hadn't gone to Africa,
like we'd be in a much better place.
Um,
so that was really complicated to think through and work through it and ended up
all working out really well and I'm extremely happy where I am now.
But that was,
there was definitely a couple of years where I was totally adrift where my Peer
Group is doing much better than I was doing and um,
where I felt like I was in the wrong field.
How did wired find you or how did,
how did it come to pass that they reached out to you with that potential offer?
Uh,
because I have a friend for whom I've had like a amazing clear overlap.
There's getting Brandon Carter and I are exactly the same age and um,
I edited something he wrote at when I was at the washed a month and he was at us
news and world report,
but that's it for last month.
And I edited and he liked the way I edited it.
And so we became friends.
And so then he left us news and got hired at New America Foundation.
And then I got hired at New America Foundation after him.
And he had recommended me and then he went to wired and he recommended me there.
And so I got hired at wired and I recommended him to my book agent.
And he ended up selling a book through that.
And then he wrote from it to New Yorker from it,
the outcomist.
And he's got the current cover story in wired.
We've had these words,
amazing,
intertwined careers and friendship that's been really terrific.
And,
uh,
he's one of those people who eat it with some people who are like the same age
and in the same field or like competitive and maybe don't always want you to
succeed.
And for whatever reason,
he and I had had a relationship where I've always only wanted him to succeed and
he's only always wanted me to succeed in.
So we'd been extremely helpful to each other.
Um,
and that's been,
that's been great.
And so look at the cover story of the next issue.
And Brendan's name is Dan.
I'm super proud of it.
I want to go back to
whatever it was,
24 hour period where you've turned down this exploding offers expiring offer for
law school yet you haven't yet.
You haven't yet been offered the job at wired.
Can you walk us through the,
the dinner,
the conversation in your head,
the sort of hours proceeding,
notifying law school that you are not going to be a curriculum because that is,
that strikes me as terrifying.
That seems completely terrifying.
I mean,
the game theory was both a little trickier and in some ways easier because there
was this third option.
Um,
I had written,
my grandfather had died and George Kennan had both died in early 2004 and I had
written an essay about their parallel lives.
And so I had also decided that maybe I would write a book about the two of them.
And so I had a proposal for a book.
So I had three things that I could do with my life and I was getting to do some
combination of one of those three things or two of those three things.
I knew that it wouldn't be time to do all three.
You can't go to law school,
worked for wired and write a book.
And so the law school offer was gonna explode mid August.
The wired option I was going to hear about relatively soon.
And the book,
I think I had sent a draft of a proposal to my agent and so I did that with him
become a reality or not a reality.
And so in some ways the decision was if I go to law school,
even if I don't get the wire job,
I still maybe have a shot at the books and the odds were like,
the odds are okay.
Um,
but I,
you know,
what do I remember about that day?
I was in Maine up at the place.
My family has up near Katie National Park where I'd spent summers from my
childhood,
which is like a very reflective,
wonderful place for the place where I always feel good and confident.
And maybe it was being there.
Maybe it was,
you know,
I,
there was some unease,
some deep unease about going to law school.
Some sense that I was giving up some sense of like,
you know,
it was the,
the week choice to make.
Um,
I don't exactly remember,
but I do remember being terrified when I wrote them and said no,
and thinking,
well this is,
you know,
you came up with a pretty good backup here,
neck.
You gave him a pretty good plan and we use a pretty awesome law school to go
through.
It's three years and you're,
you know,
you graduate,
you're guarantee or really well paying successful career license in New York,
um,
and you're throwing that away.
Um,
but I went for it.
Who knows,
who
knows,
who knows
about that a lot,
right?
Like that's active,
very few moments where your life entirely hinges upon a specific decision.
Right?
Like the choice of who you married.
But that's not really a choice.
You don't,
it's not so much like that.
Like,
I can't think of any other day that's close to it.
Um,
I mean,
I guess the choice to Wright Pam Mccarthy at the New Yorker had a,
had a big influence.
Um,
you know,
there was the choice to lead to the New Yorker to accept this wire job and that
was a pretty easy choice towards the New Yorker.
But you gotta be editor in Chief of wired,
you definitely take it.
Um,
so there,
there are a few moments but that was definitely the day where I made the choice
that had the biggest effect.
But you don't get to,
you know,
live life multiple ways.
So it seems like the right choice,
everything worked out as well as it possibly could have.
But
who knows.
I want to be respectful of your time,
so I just have just a few more questions for you.
These are,
these are my,
some of my usual questions that I like to ask.
The first is,
what book or books have you given as gifts to other people besides your own?
Oh,
that's a bad I that I can answer.
Um,
so this year for each of the last few years,
I've given one book to a bunch of people.
And,
um,
this year it's a book by Robert Reich called why Buddhism is true.
And it's a story about mindfulness and about the science of Buddhism in the
current neuroscience about how minds work,
making the argument that this game is people have said about mindfulness,
meditate,
meditation and the way it changes your capacity to empathize with other people
or just sort of break out of the tribalism that we're all walked into.
The things that Buddhism has said about that turned out to be scientifically
correct.
And here's a story about wine.
Wonderful Book.
Robert Wright as one of the smartest writers I've ever read his book non zero
is,
you know,
among my five favorite books of all time.
So that book came out recently and I gave that to um,
my closest friends and my family the year before.
I gave a book by the rest of Macfarquhar called strangers drowning because his
story about people who make extraordinary moral choices,
like the choice to adopt 23 children and bring them into your lives,
you just make crazy choices and why they make those choices.
And Marissa is one of the smartest writers at the New Yorker.
Everything she writes is absolutely brilliant and the book is brilliant,
beginning to end.
It's sort of 10 discrete chapters about people who make choices like that.
So I gave him the rest of his book last year and I'm proud of Wright's book this
year.
Yeah,
they're good.
Totally worth reading both of them.
Yeah,
they're on the,
she's always on the bottom right hand corner of my notes that I take during
these conversations.
Uh,
uh,
see him picking.
Picking here in the last few years,
could be five years,
could be 10,
could be to what behavior,
new behavior or belief has most improved positively impacted your life,
would you say?
Or has just had a very significant impact?
Um,
you know,
so my kids are nine,
seven and four now.
And thinking about the responsibilities one has to your children who will
outlive you and who in certain ways we'll carry on your personality,
um,
you carry on your life after you're gone.
I'm thinking through my responsibilities to them.
The,
how the choices I make are,
will be viewed by them when they're older.
I'm thinking about both,
how I can help them thrive and be the people they want to become.
And also how I can be somebody who when I'm gone,
they admire.
Um,
those are,
those are pretty,
those are deeply profound things.
And you know,
I had had no capacity of what it was like that children before I had children
where none.
Um,
uh,
but it's,
it's psychologically profound on,
in every,
every way.
So definitely that
or books or anything else that you found particularly helpful as a parent
with?
Um,
I don't,
you know,
I don't think I've actually read a book on parenting that changed my philosophy.
Parents,
I mean,
there are a couple of books about how to get your kids to sleep,
which is like useful technical stuff.
I haven't read,
you know,
that's interesting.
I don't think I've read a book on parenting.
I was like,
oh,
I should raise my child that way or I should talk to them this way.
It's been much more,
um,
just,
just do it and just thinking through,
Oh wait,
that wasn't the right way to talk about this,
or Oh yes,
let's try to set them,
you know,
set them up for success in this way.
Or like let's let them do this.
So let's,
let's go do this with them.
You mentioned the why Buddhism is true.
Do you have a meditation or mindfulness practice?
Um,
I kind of think the running is the substitute for that.
And when I'm running I do,
it's very much,
I don't think it's that dissimilar from mindfulness meditation because when I
run,
um,
I will be,
I guess there are two things I'd say to that.
One is the writing.
So,
you know,
do during much try to,
um,
I had to listen to podcasts or if I'm not listening to podcasts,
I'm thinking about like trying to clear my mind,
are thinking to specific things and trying to concentrate on it or paying
attention to what I see or what I hear.
Um,
so I think that's reasonably close to mindfulness meditation.
And then the second thing is I do Alexander Technique,
which is a technique I learned for playing the car just for how one positions
one bite and one's body and like aligning your heads and make sure it's straight
but your back and they sure your feet are solid in the crown.
And it was something I did when I was having,
um,
a lot of wrist pain from playing guitar far too much.
And I think that's,
that's a sort of a century techniques that also plays a similar,
similar role.
Um,
but I,
I've,
you know,
I have not figured out how to work a meditation into,
into my life.
The Alexander Technique is something that you use while you're sitting in a
chair throughout the day.
When does that,
yeah,
so something I think about of course,
as soon as I say it and I find myself like adjusting myself on the chair.
Yeah.
It's something where whenever I'm kind of out of position or I can feel like
something's not aligned,
I straighten up,
paid.
I'll try to think about where I wash my hands,
right.
I just to do just,
okay,
make sure my back,
it's the line in my hand is line and it's something that I think has prevented a
lot of injuries almost.
I've never gotten hurt while running.
So even though,
you know,
running,
running a distance that often we'll get people hurt.
And I think it's partly due to postural training,
the question that stumps people,
but you've been pretty fast on your feet,
so if you need to buy some time or pass,
that's fine as well.
If you could have a,
if you had this really metaphorically speaking,
a giant billboard on which you could put a word,
a question,
a quote,
someone else's quote,
a question,
anything really a message to get out to millions or billions of people,
what might you put on that billboard?
Uh,
you know what it is?
I'm not gonna get the exact quote,
right,
which means I'd have to stop,
check it,
but there's something that George Kennan said that,
um,
I just find like incredibly philosophically profound,
uh,
which is something I think about a lot.
Um,
not enough to remember the exact words,
but the idea was when you look at everything that goes wrong historically,
you can see deep chain of continuous mistakes that lead up to it.
And in a way that's really discouraging because it makes you think about like
each step,
like leading to greater consequences.
But on the other hand,
it's really encouraging because if you think about it and you think about,
oh wait,
what?
Did you do something right?
Can you do something?
Right?
Right now you're starting a whole another chain of events that can lead to a
really positive outcome.
And so his point when he was making the statement,
which is more or less that is even if things seem like they're going in the
wrong direction or things seem really wrong,
like you can stop and you can do something small.
That's right.
And then that will begin another chain of events that will lead to something
really good.
And so I often think about that when I'm thinking about whatever the next thing
I'm going to do is,
or the next moment is,
right.
You just are,
you're beginning a new chain of events and your chain of events that will lead
you in the right direction or you continue.
We did a good chance.
So it was,
it was bad idea from Ken and it was based on his historical studies I think
about a lot.
Yeah,
it's been great talking to you.
Thank you for taking the time.
Do you have any final words of the audience recommendation?
Anything you'd like to say before we wrap up?
No,
I,
I love talking to you.
I mean,
the thing I,
I want love people to subscribe to wired and that would be great.
Everybody subscribes to wire it.
I'll be very happy
journalists,
it's a complicated business particularly at this moment.
So we would love your support
and if they want to say hi on social and x,
talk to people all the time.
I at an annex,
Thompson on Twitter,
I'm on Linkedin,
I'm on Facebook.
There's a private page.
The other page,
I love pocket people.
I love hearing feedback.
Um,
I'm very active in comments at all that dms are open.
So I'm available.
I'm around them on the Internet.
Thank you again for taking the time.
This is a really fun conversation.
We covered a lot of interesting ground.
Thanks for your awesome questions and probing.
I was really stuck.
It was really fun.
Yes,
of course.
My pleasure and to everybody listening,
you can find links to everything wired,
the books,
resources,
and the Alexander Technique.
Among other things in the show notes for this episode and every other episode at
tim.blog/podcast.
Until next time,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the other world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance,
and it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour work,
week.com all spelled out and just drop in your email and you'll get the very
next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again,
but I ended up getting a Peloton bike and the whole system after I saw my buddy
Kevin Rose,
I've known him forever,
some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house a while back and he looked fantastic.
You've got,
I asked,
was it,
dude,
you look great.
What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing Peloton five days a week now.
That caught my attention because Kevin does nothing five days a week and you
know,
I love you Kevin,
but it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually.
But peloton is an indoor cycling bike that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting classes in your schedule or making it to a
studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite class on demand.
And in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun.
Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his iron high intensity training sessions that
are shorter like 20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and everyone
seems to have their favorite instructor or you can select by music duration and
so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that along with the realtime leaderboard are the main reasons that this
caught my attention when cycling never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller than you'd expect so it can fit in a
living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet of believe it or not and it fits with no
problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you might say bath accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever other bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and those are in the accessory category.
So this hundred dollars off is a very legit,
$100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else or are you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories including the shoes that you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code Tim.
This episode is brought to you by Linkedin and their job recruitment platform,
which offers a smarter system for the hiring process.
If you've ever hired anyone or attempted to do it,
you know that finding the right people can be extremely difficult and if you
don't have a direct referral from someone you trust,
you're left to use job boards that don't really offer any real world networking
approach and were moved by.
That is contrast.
Linkedin,
which is the world's largest professional network,
has a built in ecosystem that allows you to not only search for employees,
but also interact with them and their connections and their former employers or
colleagues in a way that closely mimics real life communication.
More than 70% of the workforce in the u s uses Linkedin and more than 22 million
professionals view and apply to linkedin every single week.
Unlike generic job boards,
linkedin considered skills,
experience,
and location to match you with candidates and making it easier to find quality
candidates.
And,
uh,
maybe above all,
you can directly contact,
uh,
candidates,
connections to get a good sense of if they are a good fit for your business.
So visit linkedin.com/tim and receive a $50 credit towards your first job post,
that's linkedin.com forward slash Tim Tim for $50 off.